[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages time to see what's
making the headlines then with the daily
mirrors associate editor Kevin McGuire
and the mail on Sundays acting Deputy
political editor Claire Ellicott welcome
to both of you so let's take a look at
the front pages shall we leading uh the
I the announcement of strike action by
the Royal College of Nursing over pay
and patient safety the first in the
rcn's 106 year history
the telegraph also leads with that story
and says half of the country's hospitals
will be affected
the star is supportive suggesting that
merely clapping for NHS workers during
the covert crisis wasn't enough
the Metro cites a report which found
that 320
000 people used a food bank for the
first time in the six months to
September
the financial times has word of a better
than expected night for Democrats in the
U.S midterm elections
but the guardian points out that Joe
Biden's party could still lose control
of Congress
the express claims an exclusive with
criticism of police for not stopping the
eco-protesters who've been causing chaos
on the country's motorways
and the sun has a story about actress
Jennifer Aniston's battle to have a baby
using IVF
well a reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
so let's go to our guests then Kevin
McGuire and Claire Ellicott and Kevin
you kick off straight to the Delhi
Telegraph nurses to Stage a first
national walk out
um you know everyone had been fearful of
this winter of discontent but certainly
striking nurses is deeply problematic
for a straining NHS
no absolutely it couldn't be a worse
time for the NHS in the sends record
waiting lists but when the Royal College
of nursing's members of 300 000 over
much of the country vote for the first
time in 106 years of that organization
to vote a strike you can see they've
reached the end of their their tether
unless the Daily Star put it they wanted
more than a jolly good clap uh this
could be quite a challenge for papers
like the telegraph the Tory press which
traditionally hostile to workers going
on strike and I'll start to trade unions
how do they handle it because they will
know that nurses are popular and
there'll be a lot of sympathy as I say
people want them to go on strike but
there will be sympathy and support for
them so they'll have to handle it rather
rather delicately as we've seen with the
trade unions Mick Lynch in particular of
the rmt uh has been a very good Advocate
uh for industrial action those strikes
have not been uh massively as unpopular
as the government would uh would have
hoped in many cases of being popular but
no it's a big moment this why is it why
is it a big moment well you can you can
see it's the cost of living crisis isn't
it it's because nurses have seen their
pay fall in real terms year after year
after year and after getting three
percent of the inflation is uh more than
12 on the retail prices in index model
uh they want more than four or five
percent yes and we saw the deli star
there hard up Hospital Heroes decided
like more than a clap of appreciation uh
everyone remembers that from the uh from
the covid days but the Daily Telegraph
um quotes Downing Street tonight saying
the plans were deeply regrettable and
the pay demand which comes with a 9
billion pound price tag was not
deliverable and that's picked up cloud
by the eye isn't it they quote the
health secretary insisting the pay
squeeze is necessary these are
economically challenging times we need a
strong economy in order to pay for a
strong Health Care system and of course
next week the black hole to be filled of
what between 50 and 60 billion is that
about right
yes of course so I think everyone would
say that nurses are some of the most
popular workers in the country and
everyone thinks they do a wonderful job
and the trouble is the contacts we are
at a time in which the economy is not
doing so well and you've got really high
inflation of about 12 of about 12 nurses
asking for a pay rise above that and
it's going to come at huge cost at a
time that the government are trying to
fill a huge fiscal hole and are going to
have to make some really difficult
decisions when they do that and um
they've already talked about who they're
going to protect talking about
protecting the most vulnerable
pensioners people on benefits and the
nurse the kind of request for an extra
paywriter nurses is coming at a time in
which you know we are in straight and
financial times and so I think it's
gonna be a really difficult thing and if
nurses go on strike at Christmas we've
got record waiting list seven million
people are waiting this the NHS is
already going to struggle in a difficult
year and with inflation costs and you
know it's just going to be really really
hard
um this this coming winter I think yes
the eye you know beginning to spell out
what might or might not be affected
um they say emergency services will
remain staffed Cancer Care also likely
to be protected but the suggestion is
that the NHS could draft in the military
to help no I don't quite know how they
would operate on the on the wards Kevin
or in the Emergency Operating theaters
now I've seen the military uh drafted in
before during fire dispute disputes to
uh to drive green green goddesses and of
course there are some soldiers in the
military who are medically uh look this
is kind of desperate from the government
because the government's weak in this
it's all over the place it's unpopular
there will be a blame game I don't think
people are going to blame nurses because
a lot of other people are feeling the
the pinch and it's it's not it's not
their fault and there will be great
sympathy for uh for these nurses and I
think the government knows that which is
why it'll go relatively soft and it's uh
it's gonna it says it's got a black hole
well are you gonna really fill it with
with nurses there's a big recruitment
shortage they're leaving the the sector
because they feel there's huge pressure
and they're not being rewarded and it's
a it's a very very strong argument that
there they were um being clapped by
ministers and conservative MPS during
the covert pandemic and then they're
asked to swallow yet again another cost
of living uh got so it's going to be a
fascinating dispute to to watch but in
the 12 years of the concert over four
elections they had the first Junior
doctors strike and now it looks like
they got the first uh strike in the 160
year history of the traditionally
moderate Royal College of Nursing
something's going wrong but I don't
think I don't think it's it's nurses I
think it's it's the government and how
it's treating Public Service workers
okay we're certainly keeping on that and
uh the other elements of the NHS who are
also balloting their members too but for
the moment um Claire let's move on shall
we to the elections in the US the the
midterm seen as crucial this time for
all sorts of reasons um and the
financial times with their headline
Democrats avoid a crushing defeat they
still risk losing control of Congress
and the Senate it looked like it might
come down to yet another runoff in
Georgia would you believe but a
fascinating night what does that mean
for Biden who suggested he'd like to
stand again or even Donald Trump who
announced a big announcement for next
Tuesday didn't he
yes so um Biden I think he's just been
speaking saying that he was breathing a
sigh of relief and uh that the Democrats
had performed better than expected and
it had been an expected Red Wave of um
Republican victories and um what's
actually happened is it it's a lot more
balanced than that and I think that um
there are some key kind of elements of
this Donald Trump was obviously hoping
that many of the candidates he endorsed
would perform really well which would
help him in terms of him getting the
Republican nomination for the 2024
um election
um instead what's actually happened is
one of his greatest competitors for that
for that um nomination is um the Florida
governor Rhonda Santos he's had a
stonking victory tonight
um so it actually looks like quite a bad
night for Donald Trump and that said
um for Joe Biden the U.S president I
think it's it's not been the night that
it's not it's not a good night for him
the House of Representatives is most
likely to fall under Republican control
and the Senate is currently on a knife
edge if Joe Biden loses control of
either of those houses he's going to
find it really difficult to get his
um agenda through it's gonna it's gonna
be a real struggle for him because he'll
be blocked by the Republicans at every
time yes and the New York Post in their
late City final
um of the Florida governor Ronda
Santos's win uh called him the future
now that would that would cause Donald
Trump to spit would it not I think
probably you know that's that's his
great fear isn't it somebody Rising some
Challenger Rising but in truth actually
you know the trump-backed although seen
as more extreme did not do so well uh in
those overnight elections Kevin
no absolutely absolutely look if if
you're looking at this who's the big
loser I think it's Donald Trump uh Joe
Biden probably in a better place for the
Democrats hoped uh but Ron DeSantis or
Rhonda sanctimonious As Trump called him
is I would have thought the clear winner
on the night because he did so well in
Florida and if he challenges Trump you
know that would see what happens with
the Republican machine but he would look
in a very good uh a very good position
to run for the Republicans uh in 2024. I
suspect Biden and the Democrats have
they got to face an opponent they want
they want it to be Trump who just put so
many people off he can yes he can
energize and excite uh quite a sizable
base but he also turns people uh people
away and it's it's interesting now when
you look at this that it appears
Democrats will lose control of the the
hazard Representatives me me just
pulling on in the Senate and that will
be seen as as a good a good result
because the Big Red Wave the big
Republican wave has just not come up
come about and much of the reason for
that is Trump who quite frankly people
don't want to return the deranged chaos
of his reign yeah I mean it'll be
absolutely fascinating this runoff in
Georgia next month if that really does
decide again for uh for the second time
in two years be quite extraordinary
Wouldn't It Anyway a lot still to watch
out for
um some key uh seats still too close to
call so we'll certainly keep an eye on
that uh plenty more still to come the
latest from the south of Ukraine and
Matt Hancock finally entering the I'm a
celebrity jungle to find out how he's
been getting on
[Music]
if you're watching the Press preview
With Me Now Kevin McGuire and Claire
Ellicott welcome back to both of you uh
Claire let's talk Ukraine shall we the
news tonight coming from Moscow that
Russians have indeed pulled out of this
key strategic city of Hesson the
difficulty of Supply is what they said
but you know they've been building
towards this for weeks now
yeah so this is a huge point in the
Ukrainian fight back against the Russian
invasion and has done as a key and
strategic place it's um it connects
Crimea which Russia invaded back in 2014
and annexed and to the mainland so it'll
be a massive loss for Putin that he no
longer controls this city so the defense
minister has ordered the troops to um
retreat but um there is some skepticism
about whether or not
um this is this is truly a sort of um
full Retreat I think zelenski has warned
that
um it may be the Russians try to learn
them into a trap but I think it's um it
was the first Regional City that uh
Regional capital city that
um Russia took from Ukraine when it
first started that Invasion all those
months ago and so it's a really really
key
um key thing that Ukraine have managed
to claw back and I think it's a very
good night for Ukraine yes we saw some
of the fighting there the long range
American artillery you know really
causing real damage in this area and the
Russians saying that 115
000 people have left but not
surprisingly Ukraine being cautious
about this um the presidential advisor
saying this evening that as long as
Ukrainian Flags don't fly over the city
of her son it makes no sense to talk
about a Russian Retreat you know not
surprising their their being cautious we
know the the Russians have been dug in
uh Kevin but uh
um you know moving to the other side of
the denipro makes more strategic sense
for the Russians it does and Ben Wallace
the UK defense minister has made that
point he said don't underestimate the
Russian army while not uh covering the
fact this is a retreat and they've given
up uh that one of their major gains and
it's strategically important because of
course it's a route from Russia to the
Crimea which was next in uh in 2014.
but if you're in in Russia you've got to
look at this Invasion and see it's been
a complete not a disaster you've your
economy it'll be tens of thousands of
Russian troops uh dead or maimed you're
losing territory territory that was
annexed and declared forever Russian by
Putin not so long ago uh so it's it's
going backwards but that's not to say
there won't be a counter-offensive at
some point although it seems Britain the
US Germany Baltic State Poland others uh
supplying modern Weaponry has made a
huge difference and the Russian army
looks like it's a poorly trained badly
equipped and terribly LED
people um apologies Kevin yes Joe Biden
also talking about this and his address
tonight saying Russia's evacuation of
hairson shows they have real problems
but we'll uh see what happens there
meantime at the moment the newspapers
have been waiting for it's fair to say
uh the Metro Matt Hancock roach having
fun with that the inside Pages too
um you know it's manna from heaven isn't
it for uh for the printed press these
pictures Claire
yes um it's fantastic I mean the former
health is actually about Hancock
obviously in the jungle for I'm a
celebrity he has um faced his first Bush
chocolate Bush Tucker trial and um it's
clear that he's getting the sort of
routine humiliation that a lot of the
public
um have um wished upon him and seems to
be raffling in it um it's quite painful
watching for members of the lobby who
have um followed his career for many
years but um no doubt the public is um
enjoying it especially after all the
lockdowns and covert addresses over the
years Kevin
yeah he's going to find out he's not as
popular as he thought I was watching
incredibly awkward and Boy George George
babatunde The Comedian Chris Miles the
the DJ all really given up a bathtub he
looks really really awkward maybe they
just need to get some PPE suits for the
Cockroaches and rats to protect them
from can't be that bad surely Kevin
McGuire and Claire Ellicott thank you
very much indeed both of you